juan orlando hernández será extraditado
a eeuu así lo ratificó la corte suprema
de justicia de honduras que rechazó su
apelación luego de analizar todos los
agravios y los elementos que fueron
presentados por la defensa técnica en la
apelación planteada ha resuelto no al
lugar el recurso de apelación planteado
lo cual significa que se confirma la
decisión del juez de primera instancia
de conceder la extradición del ciudadano
juan orlando hernández el ex presidente
hondureño es acusado por la justicia
estadounidense de conspiración para
fabricar distribuir y poseer una
sustancia controlada y llevarla a eeuu y
usar o portar armas de fuego o ayudar a
instigar al uso de las mismas según el
portavoz del poder judicial la decisión
contó con el voto unánime de los
magistrados en el cargo de narcotráfico
y 13 contra 2 con respecto al cargo de
uso de armas hernández de 53 años dijo
en una carta que compartió su esposo en
su cuenta de twitter que es inocente
todo cambió todos los planes que tenía
para mi retiro después de tantos años de
trabajo al final concluyó en la
posibilidad de que enfrentar cargos por
tres cadenas perpetuas podría llevarme a
convertirme en un muerto
esto es una venganza de los carteles es
una trama orquestada para que ningún
gobierno vuelva a hacerle frente el
exmandatario fue detenido en su
domicilio el 15 de febrero para la
petición del gobierno estadounidense y
desde entonces ha permanecido recluido
en la dirección nacional de fuerzas
especiales de la policía nacional la
detención se produjo menos de tres
semanas después de que hernández dejara
su cargo y tras años de acusaciones de
la fiscalía estadounidense sobre
presuntos vínculos con el narcotráfico